ناكل البولندي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والله شوف احنا للحين دوري ميسي ما لقيناه
بالنسبه لمباراه اليوم تحدي كبير لنا
منتخب بولندا محترفين عاليين جدا المشكله
في لاعبيتنا عندنا اصابتين الفرج
والشهراني هذول غير معوضين اذا اعطانا
الله الحظ ان شاء الله باذن الله راح نفوز
على بولندا واحد صفر اثنين صفر باذن الله
بدعم الشباب وتوفيق الله عز وجل بس مباراه
كبيره مباراه قويه فرصتنا للتاهل عاليه
جدا خصوصا بالظروف الارجنتين اللي فزنا
فيها وراحت منه فالان ركز على بولندا باذن
الله
بدعم القياده عندنا والحكومه باذن الله لا
مستحيل عليك يا السعوديه
3-0 للمنتخب السعودي سالم الدوسري هاتريك
باذن الله كارت احمر للاعب ليفه ليفه
اليوم
خليفه ما راح يسجل وبيخلص الموديل وما راح
اسجل نفس المونديال الماضي باذن الله
على غيابهم اكيد يعني تاثير كبير المنتخب
لكن البركه موجودين الجميع ان شاء الله
قادر على التعويض ولا نثق في المنتخب
مجموعه
يلا يعطيك العافيه شكرا باذن الله
تعادل اليوم 80% باذن الله
لو المعنويات عاليه باذن الله
وين وصل المنتخب السعودي بكاس العالم
ان شاء الله
ممثلين ولكن باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى ميسي
والله اكيد انا اصحاب لان الفوز مطلب تمام
والفوز راح يحقق لنا ايش الصداره باذن
الله صعبه لكن ان شاء الله قدهم يبيضون
الوجه نحقق النتيجه
ممكن يؤثر على الاداء المنتخب السعودي
اليوم
المباراه الماضيه كان مرتاحين صحيح بس
داخليا كان يطمحونه الفوز الماضي راح يولد
فوز ان شاء الله همم اليوم باذن الله
اكثر صحيح
باذن الله باذن الله انا اكثر لكن انا
اتوقع واهم شيء الفوز اهم شيء الفوز كده
يمشي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سلام سلام